en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre la
ley de la demanda que es una de las
ideas principales de microeconomía y
felizmente para nosotros es una idea
algo intuitiva ella nos dice que si
aumentamos el precio de un producto esto
hará disminuir la cantidad de demanda
del producto es decir la cantidad de
demanda va a caer y viceversa tú ya
puedes imaginar el otro lado de esto si
disminuimos el precio de un producto
esto era aumentar la cantidad de demanda
de este producto y entonces la cantidad
de demanda pues subida esto es en
general lo que la ley de la demanda dice
sin embargo en los próximos vídeos
veremos que hay algunas excepciones a
todo esto pero para hacer esta idea un
poco más concreta vamos a pensar sobre
la demanda de un cierto producto y ahora
una cosa que voy a dejar en claro aquí y
haré un gran esfuerzo para intentar
explicarlo es que cuando hablamos sobre
la palabra demanda en un sentido
económico formal no estamos hablando
sobre una cantidad de hecho estamos
hablando todo lo demás es igual setter
is paribus estaríamos hablando sobre
todas las relaciones
el precio y la cantidad demandada si
queremos hablar sobre la cantidad en sí
debemos decir la cantidad demandada
entonces tenemos la demanda contra la
cantidad demandada estas son dos cosas
diferentes si esto es un poco más
confuso para ti ahora afortunadamente al
final de este vídeo
la diferencia entre demanda y cantidad
demandada será mucho más clara y mejor
aún en los siguientes vídeos no te va a
quedar duda alguna porque en este vídeo
vamos a enfocarnos en como los cambios
en la cantidad demandada son relativos
al precio en los vídeos futuros
hablaremos sobre toda la relación como
la demanda cambia basada en diferentes
factores para aclarar las cosas digamos
que estoy a punto de lanzar un libro de
ciencia ficción sobre espacio o sobre lo
que sea algo como julio verne no sé no
importa tanto qué libro voy a lanzar lo
que sí es importante es que es un libro
electrónico y hemos hecho un estudio de
mercado o simplemente conocemos el
precio o como la demanda se relaciona
con el precio o el precio se relaciona
con la demanda y para esto vamos a
mostrar una tabla de demanda que no
solamente es una tabla porque en esta
tabla se muestra
como el precio y changos acabo de
comentar mi primer error dije como el
precio se relaciona con la demanda
debería decir como el precio se
relaciona con la cantidad de demanda y
bueno como la cantidad de demanda se
relaciona con el precio entonces la
tabla siguiente es la que me va a
relacionar el precio con la cantidad
demandada y entonces todo lo demás es
constante entonces tenemos una columna
acerca de escenarios otra sobre precio y
la tercera sobre cantidad demandada así
que vamos a hacer el primer escenario y
en cada uno de los escenarios vamos a
poner un precio y además la cantidad de
gente que va a descargar este libro
electrónico el primer escenario vamos a
llamarlo el escenario
y voy a suponer que en este escenario le
pongo un precio a mi libro electrónico
de dos pesos y por lo tanto tendré
muchas personas descargando lo a ese
precio van a ser como unas 60.000
personas que descargan este libro a un
precio de 2 pesos perfecto ahora veamos
un escenario ve en este escenario bbva
aumentar el precio de 2 pesos a 4 pesos
y esto mata gran parte de la demanda
ahora la cantidad de la demanda cae y va
a ser de 40 mil personas descargando la
en un escenario se voy a subir hasta 6
pesos y por lo tanto la cantidad de
demanda va a bajar hasta 30 mil personas
y haré un par más de estos en el
escenario de aumento el precio en otros
dos pesos así que ahora tengo el precio
de ocho pesos y la cantidad de demanda
pues va a seguir cayendo va a caer hasta
veinticinco mil personas ya era uno más
veamos que color me falta qué color me
falta el amarillo no he usado el
amarillo así que en el escenario aumento
el precio hasta diez pesos y ahora la
cantidad de demanda va a ser de 23.000
personas entonces esta relación esto
muestra la ley de la demanda justo aquí
en esta tabla se muestra como la
cantidad demandada se relaciona con el
precio y viceversa y es justo a esto a
lo que llamamos tabla de demanda y lo
padre es que también podemos basados en
la tabla de la demanda dibujar la curva
de la demanda lo que haremos es
identificar estos puntos y dibujar una
curva que los conecte porque éstos
los únicos escenarios cualquier otra
cosa entre ellos también es posible
podemos cobrar no sé dos pesos con un
centavo por el libro o podemos cobrar
cuatro pesos con 50 centavos por el
libro qué sé yo y es eso lo que la curva
de la demanda muestra un poco mejor así
que vamos a tratar de dibujar esta curva
porque es una curva continua y no
solamente tienen cinco puntos entonces
vamos a graficar la esta es una de las
convenciones de la economía de la cual
no soy fan porque muchas personas
frecuentemente hablan sobre el cambio
del precio y como la cantidad demandada
cambia a partir de eso y en la mayoría
de los estudios en las matemáticas y la
ciencia lo que está cambiando
normalmente lo colocas en el eje
horizontal entonces si yo fuera
responsable de las convenciones en la
economía colocaría el precio en el eje
horizontal pero en el modo en el que se
hace tradicionalmente el precio está
colocado en el eje vertical y tú estás
acostumbrado a verlo del modo
tradicional en que se dan las clases así
que haré lo mismo ya tenemos el precio y
la cantidad demandada entonces la
cantidad demandada va hasta 60 mil
personas mientras que el precio máximo
es de 10 pesos
por tanto tengo 10 20 30 40 41 45 50 y
hasta 60 mil personas esto está dado en
miles de personas y bueno el precio va
hasta 10 pesos por lo tanto va de 2 a 10
pesos vamos a poner los 2 4 6 8 10 aquí
dos cuatro seis ocho y diez pesos y
ahora vamos a poner los puntos de cada
una de la tablet de la demanda en el
escenario a tenemos 60 mil personas y un
precio de 2 pesos este es el escenario
en el escenario ve el precio aumenta
hasta 4 pesos y tenemos una cantidad de
40 mil personas entonces este de aquí va
a ser mi escenario ve en el escenario sé
de color magenta tenemos un precio de 6
pesos y 30 mil personas que van a
descargar el libro entonces este es el
escenario se en el escenario de tenemos
un precio de 8 pesos y 25 mil personas
que descargan el libro esté por aquí
aquí mero va a ser mi escenario de aquí
van a ser 25 mil personas y entonces
aquí tengo
y escenario de y en el último escenario
en el escenario
tenemos el precio más alto de 10 pesos y
solamente 23.000 personas descargan el
libro por lo tanto tenemos este
escenario el escenario
y bueno si unimos todos los puntos
entonces tenemos la curva de la demanda
y ella sería más o menos así la curva de
la demanda va a lucir algo por este
estilo y estoy haciendo lo mejor para
dibujar una línea recta y continua sería
algo más o menos así lo que estoy
intentando pensar es que esta curva
seguiría este camino estas son formas
para mostrar la demanda y volver a
repetir lo que dije antes y dice la
cantidad demandada tiene un precio dado
es decir la gente está dispuesta a bajar
oa comprar mi libro electrónico cuando
hablamos de la demanda en sí estamos
hablando sobre toda esta relación así
que la demanda en sí es toda esta tabla
de demanda o dicho de otra manera otra
forma de explicar qué es la demanda es
toda esta curva de demanda si la demanda
cambiará tendríamos una curva distinta a
esta curva lo que quiere decir que esta
curva se desplazaría o las entradas de
esta tabla
ahora bien si la cantidad de demanda
cambia nos movemos a lo largo de esta
curva todo lo demás se mantiene
constante y solo va a cambiar el precio
así que afortunadamente esto lo hace
todo mucho más claro cuando todo es
constante y solamente cambias el precio
no estás cambiando la demanda estás
cambiando la cantidad demandada la
demanda no cambia porque todo se
mantiene constante en esta relación en
los siguientes vídeos vamos a pensar en
qué pasa cuando cambias algunos de estos
otros factores nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo